ho io guardo bene dicono va a casa
io rispondo sono già qua di bibi cara
italia chi mi messaggio per i ragazzi e
benvenuti e se lo sapete oltre che la
canzone di galli è uscita anche la
canzone di pan della scuola chi sarà chi
sarà tisana non sapete di cosa sto
parlando
meglio perché facciamo la reaction
partecipato anche io al w mente non vi
dico che parte ho fatto ma potreste
immaginarvi lo si è pronti avrei voluto
un sacco farci la parola i ragazzi solo
che la canzone in sé è già una parodia
quindi giubbotti di uscire o mango io
non sono qui il caso con la mia tisana
tisana tisana marijuana
prima di partire per cortesia io ho
registrato ivan della sono quindi io so
più o meno come registrano una scena che
vedete che dura un secondo per farla ci
è voluta magari 1 ora no io mi immagino
daniel che per un'ora e attaccato con la
faccia sul pavimento per un'ora e mezza
dove girano così
scaldati una brasiliana
ecco quei denti che voi vedete lì
ovviamente non sono d'oro ma sono di
plastica presi e dal marocchino dietro
casa proprio presicce gliel'hanno
staccati dei denti non è che li hanno
comprati quindi erano prosport chi non
stavano su neanche per sbaglio quindi io
nella canzone dovevo cantare quel che
cantano ipantellas prima che ogni volta
che apriva la bocca
mica scavano i denti della infattibile
quindi dovevo rimanere tipo così era una
roba molto triste quanto vedete però pur
attiva
ogni volta che vi vedo non ci posso fare
perché mi ricordo che per rimanere
guarda guarda che frame guarda come mi
fanno apparire brutto ipantellas mi
metto di frame apposta
mi hanno detto fa vj tu sei bello e devi
fare il brutto nel nostro video loro
detto ok daniel te lo giuro per ripicca
ti faccio vestire da donna e nel mio
prossimo horror ogni volta che mi
spavento devi accarezzarmi capelli e non
è una bella cosa ti va
ma è una figura mille tisane
dietro dietro a caso è sfruttato pietra
non c'entra niente proprio bene
sarà come carico bello dietro
qualcuno ha la codeina questa la codeina
è una droga è una droga marijuana
la gente quando lei una prateria
scusate se stop di tre secondi ma io gli
devo fare lo so che sono una rottura ma
io devo farvi capire dei punti che
magari voi non dovete riascoltarli per
capirlo nè pietro tanto che fa ridere ma
è quello che hanno messo nella canzone
quando c'è pietro che fa ridere perché
più calda di una brasiliana e hanno
messo pietro bravo così si fa
stasera io resto qua sopra nessuno
unesco sono persone il mio sotto so mica
eminem tucci tiri il malocchio noi
beviamo una tisana al finocchio
noi ci abbiamo design fino
chi vuole che mora si salvi finocchio
non ci vedo niente
[Musica]
buona che va bene quest'uomo che tra
l'altro è simpaticissimo e che ho
conosciuto quando ho fatto ha ripreso
anch'io quando ha dovuto registrare
questa cosa e quindi fare la parte in
questo caso della tisana al finocchio ha
detto una frase che vi rimarrà per
sempre in testa sco verbo pensano
avranno pagato come comparsa ha detto
tipo cosa mi tocca fare per pagare il
mutuo della casa
[Musica]
ditemi se non sembriamo gente è uscita
da un centro di recupero alla fine così
ci siamo proprio ciao non bevo codeina
da un sacco questa è la tisana dei
pantella si sa cosa c era in quella
tisana vabbè ragazzuoli comunque
passando ad altro io avevo registrato e
questa cosa non avevo ancora messa
lavoro registrato un paio di mesi fa una
clip che andrà poi in social dream dove
e colorato l'occhio di un da roma per
esprimere un desiderio e vi lascio
questa clip cavo registrato appunto un
po di tempo fa
in questo modo molto discoteca questo po
il mio da roma e funzionano e da roma
anche quando si esprimono i desideri si
cerchia l'altro occhio quindi adesso lo
volevo cerchiare mentre registro così
questa è una cosa molto spirituale il
desiderio lo vedrete poi quando uscirà
il film perché l'ho espresso espresso
durante le riprese
se volete anche voi esprimono un
desiderio e farvi il video registratevi
mandate la clip al link che vi lascio in
descrizione quindi direi che per oggi
possiamo concludere qua ragazzi miei
splendidi sia piaciuto un senso vero
cemento mi piace anche ai soci ha
condotto da nel picchiare senza dove si
schieri e noi ci vediamo dove minchia il
telecomando l'anno appese vicini a qua
che ormai guarda ho perso tutto anche la
dignità dopo la canzone dei punt hellas
ragazzi
[Musica]